on parle de d'enfants en parle pas
d'adultes donc les enfants sont instable
émotionnellement
si les parents exercent une autorité
justement parentale ce que la loi leur
reconnaît c'est que ça prouve que ces
enfants ne sont pas disposés ou alors
suffisamment armé pour faire des choix
réfléchis donc et puis et moi ce qui
m'inquiète beaucoup que ce soit ces
jeunes filles vous parlais tout à
l'heure de ces garçons et pourquoi pas
des garçons sexy c'est de voir cette
jeunesse finalement condamné à exister
par la séduction on n'existe que par la
séduction et c'est comme ça c'est ce que
disait mona chollet qu'on s'en fait un
finalement dans une situation de de
subordination permanente d'être toujours
dans d'être sous l'emprise finalement de
cette tyrannie du look de la beauté de
plaire à tout prix etc
je pense que c'est pour ça que je le
disais au début le débat est vraiment
mal posée parce que la question de
l'hypersexualisation des jeunes filles
et même des jeunes garçons et même des
jeunes garçons il ya énormément de
politique que ce soit aux états unis au
canada qui s'y intéresse parce qu' on
s'inquiète véritablement de l'impact sur
la sur le sur la santé psychique la
santé mentale la santé physique de cette
hyper sexualisation que je trouve qu on
occulte beaucoup dans ce débat à cause
de ce sondage qui forcément clive
[Musique]